guess what I got
what is that Danny why this is the flip
Mino HD so now it's HD it's nowadays she
yes hopefully HD yeah it's a big picture
in a little package it's a very small
package yeah essentially the same
hardware but it just takes video and
high-definition oh whoa what do you this
is the kodak zi6 Wow Sisu zi6 CI CI six
right now the eye is silent I see well
why do you have that well I might why
are you trying to mess up my foot minnow
HD okay well here's the deal I like this
comparison because basically these are
two camcorders boast kind of the same
market they're all gonna be
approximately 100 to 200 Auto range and
it just seemed like you know let's see
how they stack up these are these are
basically cameras that are made for
recording videos relatively quickly and
then uploading them to the Internet the
quality when we compared it to the first
generation flip was it was remarkable
fantastic I mean the colors were really
clear well this guy but this guy has
something to say about that yeah you
sure which is essentially when we shot
suicide by side footage with this one
and the flip first was the kodak dht22
HD cameras it was it was incredible it
was shocking yeah yeah I was shocked in
slyly appalled yeah and a little aroused
little odd
okay well the picture is much better on
this one but is this one you have to be
more expensive right
it is fifty dollars cheaper than that
one Wow that's it for ya you're just
you're over it I'm done I'm not even a
touch I'm washing my hands of that so
basically you're paying you know you're
paying for the flip the new minnow HD
you're paying for a picture that isn't
quite as good as what Kodak's already
has on the market for $50 cheaper right
all you're basically paying for is a
smaller more polished package right
which I don't know I mean is it worth it
you know yeah I like to be able to toss
them around mm-hmm you like to toss your
200 I like it on her camera love to how
much memory does that guy have 4
gigabytes and total memory and you're
really stoked on that and no I'm not
stoked no no no why would I be stoked on
on
memory I know and that's upgradeable to
what 32 it's a gradual 32 that's
ridiculous
I'm gonna give this one a solid eight
balls out of ten to read more about
these delicious cameras go to wire.com
slash reviews and you can read the full
overview of the flip Mino HD as well as
the kodak zi6 yeah yeah great here's a
nifty little stocking stuffer for the
iphone lover in your life this is a
Griffin's clarify case and you know like
most iPhone users I am constantly
searching for the perfect case to
protect my delicate beloved little
precious phone object the clarify case
is a is a case that actually does
something different it improves the
camera quality on the iPhone and the way
it does that is it's got a tiny little
plastic lens here and it's sort of a
cheap lens it's not a big deal but what
it does is it makes the close-up photos
on the iPhone a lot sharper in fact
these might be the sharpest photos
you'll ever take with your iPhone and
that's really handy if you use the phone
for close-up work to take pictures of
say business cards or books that you're
taking notes of or anything that you
might want to get closer to than about
18 inches if you want to take pictures
of your friends or of landscapes or
something you just slide it out of the
way this works really well with an
application called Evernote which lets
you take notes by basically just
snapping pictures of things it does
optical character recognition OCR on any
text that it finds in the picture so
that you can then search on that later
it's really handy if you're a researcher
or a journalist like I am or if you just
want to you know take pictures of wine
labels as you drink the the bottle of
wine the best thing about griffin's
clarify case is that it's just about $20
retail so if you know somebody with an
iPhone this is a really good choice for
a little holiday present